on the 28th of november
gunfire was heard in the hills
surrounding aksum
a historical city and place of
pilgrimage
in the ethiopian region of tigre
but these shots mark the beginning of a
period
of unspeakable violence and mass
executions
according to amnesty international
the details alleged by witnesses who
contributed
to their report whomever was on the
street
was killed the sidewalks of aksum
so many young people were lay down you
can see them
bleeding like some of them their bodies
swollen
um this the cities start to smell
amnesty compiled accounts from dozens of
witnesses
who fled into neighboring sudan as well
as telephone interviews
with survivors in aksum sixty thousand
crossed the border
after the ethiopian government and the
authorities in tigre
went to war last november
allegations of atrocities and ethnic
bloodletting
were rife
and sky news saw evidence of horrific
injuries
from refugees seeking sanctuary
in aksum troops from eritrea fighting
with the ethiopians
says amnesty systematically killed
many hundreds of local men gunning them
down
as they attempted to flee these images
filmed in the center of the city says
the human rights group
we spoke to someone by phone who says he
witnessed
the shooting of men and boys
they killed the man on boys
on the streets even two electoral troops
shoot
those who tried to remove bodies from
the streets
that i saw satellite imagery
published by amnesty appears to indicate
mass burial sites near two churches in
the city
and a woman who said she was in aksum at
the time
told us bodies were left in the streets
for days
some were eaten by hyenas but that day
that's a nightmare day the china
oh my god hi nah nah eat it i
not eaten oxen people's body
the ethiopian government says its law
enforcement operation
to crush tigrayan fighters has largely
succeeded
but the region remains cut off for the
most part
to the outside world humanitarian
agencies
have been prevented from delivering
crucial supplies
particularly in rural areas we are still
struggling every day to have access
to to allow our drugs and medicines and
the international
support that they they deserve to to
to get in and this is uh this is uh this
is very frustrating
this is uh something that is the most
difficult part
amnesty says it gathered testimony from
more than 40 witnesses
but the ethiopian government has
questioned the organization's findings
while the eritreans called the report
preposterous
any prospect of an international
investigation
is slim john sparks sky news